voici les gens bien
nova
et je suis à environ bonsoir d'envoyer
un n'importe qui je sais pas ce que dira
stéphanie mais bon alors richard viron
que trois dates qui raconte votre vie
deuxième au tour de france 1998 est
accusé de dopage et exclu du tour ainsi
que tous les coureurs de l'équipe
festina et 2000 après avoir nié pendant
27 mois vous passer aux aveux
votre descente aux enfers votre mensonge
vaut aveu vous raconter tout ça dans un
livre qui est publié chez robert laffont
et qui s'appelle plus fort qu'avant vous
savez comment on fait les chars virenque
attention
il voulait pas lâcher guidon mais il est
mis 27 mois pourra jouer en même temps
bien alors donc ce livre est écrit en
collaboration avec jean paul vespini qui
est journaliste à la provence pour un
petit peu parler de boom un petit peu
parlé de votre vie richard virenque
richard virenque vous êtes né au maroc
où votre père travailler pour la société
kléber colombes vos parents avaient une
ville à casablanca dans le quartier
français et vous partiez passer vos
week-ends à 50 km de là la plage de dao
mais il y avait trois tentes une tente
cuisine il tente chambre une tante
débarras et vous alliez pêcher des sols
avec le zodiac à marée basse
et puis votre famille il était obligé de
rentrer en france à cause d'un racisme
anti français vous dites est obligé
d'aller à l'école accompagnés vivre avec
les volets fermés à la maison les gens
jettent des pierres sur les volets ils
ont tué votre chien ils ont tué votre
berger allemand au nom 178 les français
ça commence et quand ce n'était pas bien
vu et et ma mère avait envie de rentrer
en france
donc on est rentré dans le var le maroc
reste pour vous une sorte de paradis
perdu d'une certaine façon oui ces
scellés plage le soleil la chaleur est
bon plein de souvenirs de plage j'ai pu
découvrir et vous rentrez sans votre
petit vélo vert sur lequel vous aviez
appris à pédaler parce que c'est des
lots y avait pas de place pour lui dans
les valises contenant des fils de
téléphone
on croit être fort et puissant
voilà et alors heureusement la vie vers
l'âge de 12 13 ans votre frère lieu mais
elle vous fait découvrir le cyclisme et
vous rentrez dans un vélo club
vous commencez à faire vos débuts de
cyclistes déduit amateurs donc on
commence à 14 ans et après on enchaîne
toutes les catégories et à partir de 17
ans j'ai commencé à avoir les capacités
pour penser aller un peu plus loin dans
le jeu mais ça marche très bien parce
que dès l'âge de 18 ans il ya un tour
régional et vous remporté cinq étapes
sur six donc très rapidement vous
révéler être un très bon cycliste
ce succès c'est pour vous faire
pardonner vos échecs scolaires
oui c'est parce que je me suis un moment
je me suis un peu réfugier dans le vélo
parce que je sentais que c'était
peut-être là où vous avez un avenir et à
l'école je me sentais vraiment pas bien
juste et plus là pour pour animer la
classe et pour être un peu le pitre
ouais que pour faire j'irai apprendre à
travailler je me sentais mieux à
l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur puis vous
devancé l'appel pour le service
militaire et vous allez au bataillon de
joinville donc des jeunes niveau bien
entendu et puis si le début de votre
carrière en 92 à 22 ans c'est votre
premier tour de france s est maillot
jaune pour la deuxième étape est là
toute la nuit vous posez le maillot sur
une sur une chaise et toute la nuit pour
garder le maillot
oui ben siégeons toute la nuit répondre
oui
faut changer une couleur non mais c'est
de rentrer dans le tour de france en
étant néo professionnel et d'arrivée de
gagner le maillot jaune maillot le plus
convoité de prendre mais aussi à pois le
maillot vert si jamais rafler tous les
maillots j'ai rentré dans une rixe en
matière du tour par la grande porte et
ensuite eh ben ça a été géré c'est monté
crescendo et j'ai toujours aimé le tour
de france
vous dites mon premier tour de france je
vais accompli à l'eau claire
j'ai fini 25e oui mais bon c c'est
prometteur quand on est jeune on ma
vraie vie héroïque en reprenant deux
trois trucs qu'on veut finir premier en
même temps oui peut-être ainsi mai
j'avais une carrière qui s'ouvrait
novembre alors si lors de votre
troisième tour de france que vous êtes
confrontés au dopage pour la première
fois donc vous rentrez dans l'équipe
festina la fameuse équipe de bruno
roussel et de vie veux tu
et puis du fameux bernard scène le
docteur mabuse
alors là vous raconter dans votre
bouquin comment ça se passe d'ailleurs
vous dites ça se déroule comme une
visite médicale normal oui quand
l'époque il y avait les règles étaient
simples
il y avait des contrôles qui était
instaurée et il fallait pas dépasser
giresse à rester aux contrôles urinaires
ouais et donc il y avait beaucoup de
substance qui n'était pas retrouvée donc
on n'était pas dans les prises de sang
donc à l'époque j'avais la vie était
belle pour les contrôles donc
quand l affaire festina a éclaté ben ça
a changé la donne et est-ce que vous
avez essayé le pot belge
oui c'est ce que c'est le pot belge
michel c'est un mélange mélange cocktail
qui vivent à tout d'abord il ya une
sensation de
dodo faurie les cheveux qui pousse sur
la tête ça peut marcher
en tous les cas à richard virenque vous
êtes le seul français à avoir revêtu
cinq fois le maillot à pois rouges du
meilleur grimpeur
ça fait rêver un meilleur grimpeur
et puis le 8 juillet 98 ville veut tu
est arrêté à la frontière franco-belge
donc avec sa voiture bourrée de dope on
voit pleurer devant les caméras de
france 2 vous partez en hélico avec
votre frère vous êtes mis 30 heures en
garde à vue et vous dites dans votre
livre le roi de la montagne se retrouve
au fond du trou
c'est un truc et vous emmène fait une
fouille rectale quoi alors richard les
policiers vous disent les autres ont
avoué
pourquoi tu n'avoues pas vous refuser
parce que je savais que le moment
j'allais parler
j'allais moto suspendre donc
celui qui parlait il était suspendu et
pratiquement donc comme je l'avais
jamais subi de contrôle positif
ouais donc et pas de trop avant même
temps non alors là le public commence à
réaliser que donc t-il à armstrong mais
finalement tous les cyclistes se sont
toujours dopés que robert chapatte le
savait et qui nous avait rien dit voilà
les médias vous tombe dessus
les guignols évidemment un à l'insu de
mon plein gré chaque séquence devenue un
classique maintenant comment à l'époque
vous regardé les guignols
non je suis tombé sur quelques j'irai
série où quelques clips des guignols y
en a quelques-uns qui m'ont qui m'ont
choqué qu'ils m'ont fait mal
ouais j'en fais mal à mes proches et il
y en a quelques-uns qui m'ont fait rire
aussi
et là y'a un truc et s est
incompréhensible c'est qu'en 99 malgré
tout vous réintégrer le tour pour vice
de forme
or le blanc vient vous serrer la main
mais pas devant les caméras enfin tout
le monde est un petit peu gêné vous
prenez le départ avec un garde du corps
à côté de vous en passer situation un
petit peu étrange et en 2000 vous avouez
vous dites oui c'est vrai j'ai pris des
produits dopants
j'avais pas le choix alors le président
du tribunal vous dis mais finalement
votre maillot à pois vous l'avez arraché
de le perron je vous répondais cette
phrase définitif
si vous croyez qu'il suffit de se mettre
des piqûres dans le cul pour avancer il
a été mené en et 15 min sans way
suspendu neuf mois donc et au coi pour
la d2
quand on dépassait le seuil de 50 cl
avec un jour 2 de vacances et moi comme
j'ai avoué
donc c'est comme un cas positif donc on
m'a suspendu mais les coureurs qui
avaient été suspendues à l'époque avant
moi pour les mêmes faits donc les mes
copines christina qui avait avoué
il avait une suspension trois mois
l'hiver sans compétition et trois mois
en saison en compétition et moi la
sucent paul qu'on a mis la suspension je
me suis dit bon je vais prendre un peu
plus parce que j'ai j'ai un peu attendu
avant de parler et là ils m'ont mis neuf
mois à faire donc aujourd'hui c'est j'ai
été le courant le plus suspendu
maintenant vous êtes clean
oui vous roulez à l'eau claire l'a fait
vous avez plus jamais gagné si
maintenant des abonnements les autres se
dope
si vous dopez pas vous n'avez pas gagné
j'ai gagné une des plus belles courses
paris tours en 2001 hc
vous n'aviez rien pris ce jour là un
homme non donc on peut faire du vélo ce
sens des français
et oui en gagnant une coupe du monde la
plus plate devant les grands sprinteurs
j'ai fait 240 kilomètres d'échappée
ouais le vent de face avec jacky durand
et j'ai tenu tête au peloton je sais
c'est pour ça que l'équipe domo vous à
vous a gardé les richard virenque
si vous étiez sûr de gagner le tour de
france
en vous dopants mais sans être pris est
ce que vous le feriez saisir gagner le
tour de france on doit penser après oui